And this is something else I
wanted to talk to you about.
You know when you're,
you're an admirer of Eric.
No,
I'm an n of Carl Young.
Yeah.
And that's the norm.
And connection is really interesting
cause I think he's a bloody genius.
I really liked the great mother's a great
book and I really a great warning that
book and also the origins and
history of consciousnesses.
What am I most influential book.
Yeah.
That's so interesting.
I read an essay you wrote,
I don't remember when it was fair.
Nyu.
Yes.
It's always been staggering to me that
that book hasn't had the impact that it
should have had.
I mean you'll himself in the
preface to that book who wrote that,
that was the book that he
wished that he would've written.
It's very much associated with young
symbols of transformation and it was a
major influence on my book.
Maps of meaning,
which was an attempt to outline
the universal archetypes
that that are portrayed
in the kind of religious
structures that you,
that you put forward.
But the thing that I really see happening,
and you can tell me what
you think about this,
and in Norman's book consciousness,
which is masculine,
symbolically masculine
for a variety of reasons,
is,
is viewed as rising up against the
countervailing force of tragedy from an
underlying co feminine,
Symbolically Feminine unconsciousness,
right?
And it's something that can always be
pulled back into that unconsciousness.
That would be the microcosm of that
would be the Friday and eatable mother
familial dynamic where the mother was
so over protective and all encompassing
that she interferes with the
development of the competence,
not only of her sons,
but also of her daughters,
of her children in general.
And it seems to me that that's the
dynamic that's being played out in our
society right now,
is that there's this,
and it's,
it's related in some way that
I don't understand to this,
to this insistence that all forms
of masculine authority or nothing by
tyrannical power.
So the symbolic representation
is tyrannical father with
no appreciation for the
benevolent father and benevolent mother
with no appreciation whatsoever for the
tyrannical mother.
Right.
And that's that.
And cause I thought of videology
is as fragmentary mythologies.
That's where they get their archetype
archetypal in psychological power,
right?
And so in a balanced representation,
you have the terrible mother and the
great mother as as noise and laid out so
nicely and you have the terrible
father and the great father.
So that's the fact that culture
bangles you have to death well.
It's also promoting
you and developing you.
You have to see that as balanced.
And then you have the heroic
and adversarial individual.
But in the postmodern world,
and this seems to be something that's
increasingly seeping out into the culture
at large,
you have nothing but
the tyrannical father.
Nothing but the destructive
force of masculine consciousness
and nothing but the
benevolent,
great mother.
And it's a,
it's an appalling ideology.
And it seems to me that it's
sucking the vitality went to,
which is exactly what you
would expect symbolically.
It's sucking the vitality of our culture.
You see that with the
increasing demolition of,
of young men,
um,
and not only young men in terms
of their academic performance,
which like they're falling way behind in
elementary school way behind in junior
high and bailing out of
the universities like mad.
And so,
and I,
I,
well the public school
education has become completely
permeated by this kind of
anti male propaganda.
I mean,
and to me public schools are
just a form of imprisonment.
You know,
right now are particularly destructive
to young men who have a lot of physical
energy.
Right now I identify as transgender,
Gay Mike Myself,
right?
But I do not,
I do not require the entire
world to alter itself okay.
To,
to fit my particular on the self image.
I do believe in the power of hormones.
I believe that men exist and women
exist and are biologically different.
I think that,
I think there is no cure for the cultural
ills right now except if men start
standing up away and demanding that
they be respected as men again.
So I got a question about that.
So,
so one of the things,
we did a research project a year ago,
trying to figure out if there was such
a thing as political correctness from a
psychometric perspective to find out is
there the loose aggregation of beliefs
actually clumped together statistically.
And we actually found two factors,
which I won't go into,
but then we looked at things
that predicted adherence to that.
Now,
uh,
politically correct creed,
there were a couple that were surprising.
One was being female was a predictor,
the personality attributes
associated with femininity.
So that would be agreeableness and
higher levels of negative emotion.
We're also both independent predictors
but so were symptoms of personality
disorder,
which I thought was really important
because part of what I see happening is
that like,
I think that women whose
relationship with men have,
has been seriously pathologized,
cannot distinguish between male authority
and competence and male tyrannical
power.
Like they failed to differentiate because
all they see is the oppressive mail.
And then they may have
had experiences that,
that,
um,
there were experiences with men
might've been rough enough so that that
differentiation never occurred because it,
it has to occur.
And you have to have a lot of experience
with men and good men do before that
will occur.
But it seems to me that we're also
increasingly dominated by a view of
masculinity that's mostly characteristic
of women who have terrible personality
disorders and who are unable to
have healthy relationships with men.
Now.
But here's the problem.
You know,
this is something my
wife has pointed out to.
She said,
well,
man are going to have to
stand up for themselves.
But here's the problem.
I know how to stand up to a man who's,
who's,
uh,
unfairly trespassed against me.
And the reason I know that is because the
parameters for my resistance are quite
well defined,
which is we talk,
we argue,
we push,
and then it becomes physical,
right?
Like if,
if we move beyond the
boundaries of civil discourse,
we know what the next step is.
Okay.
That's forbidden in,
in discourse with women.
And so I don't think that
men can control crazy women.
I don't think,
I really don't believe it.
I think that they have to
throw their hands up in,
in,
in what?
In,
in.
It's not even disbelief.
It's that the cultural,
there's no step forward that you can
take under those circumstances because if
the man is offensive
enough and crazy enough,
the reaction becomes physical right away.
Or at least the threat is there and when
men are talking to each other in any
serious manner,
that underlying thread and
physicality is always there,
especially if it's a real conversation
and keeps the thing civilized to some
degree.
You know,
if you're talking to a man who wouldn't
fight with you under any circumstances
whatsoever,
then you're talking to someone to
whom you have absolutely no respect,
but I can't see any way.
For example,
there's a,
there's a woman in in Toronto who's
been organizing this movement,
let's say against me and some other people
who are going to do with free speech
event and she managed to organize quite
effectively and she's quite ofensive.
You might say,
she compared us to Nazis,
for example,
which,
you know,
publicly using the swastika,
which wasn't really something
I was all that fond of,
but I,
I'm defenseless against
that kind of female insanity
because the techniques that
I would use against a man
who was employing those
tactics are forbidden to me.
So I don't know,
like it seems to me that it isn't man
that have to stand up and say enough of
this,
even though that is what they should do.
It seems to me that it's saying women
who have to stand up against their crazy
sisters and say,
look,
enough of that enough man
hating enough pathology,
enough bringing disgrace on us as a,
as a gender.
But the problem there,
and then I'll start my little tirade,
is that most of the women I know who
are sane are busy doing same things,
right?
They're off.
They have their career,
they have their family,
they're quite occupied and they don't
seem to have the time or maybe even the
interest to go after there.
They're crazy harpy sisters.
And so I don't see any
regulating force for that,
that terrible femininity.
And it seems to me to be invading the
culture and undermining the masculine
power of the culture in a way that's,
I think fatal.
I really do believe that.
I too,
I too believe that these are,
this is symptomatic of the
decline of Western culture and,
and we,
and,
and it will just go down flat.
I don't think people realize that,
you know,
masculinity is still exists.
Okay.
In the world as a code among jihadists.
And when you have passionate masculinity.
Okay.
Circling the borders,
like the huns in the vandals
during the Roman empire,
that that's what I see.
I see this culture rotting from within.
Okay.
And this Oh,
link itself,
literally now my island overview
of why we're having these problems.
So I,
and it comes from the fact that I'm
the product of an immigrant family.
All four of my grandparents and
my mother were born in Italy.
So I remember from my earliest years in
this factory town in upstate New York
where,
but my relatives came to
work in the shoe factory.
I can remember still.
Okay.
They,
the life of the agrarian era.
Okay.
Which we now,
which was for most of human history,
the agrarian era where there was the
world of men and the world of women and
they sex has had very little
to do with each other.
Each had power and
status and its own realm.
Right?
And,
and they,
and they laughed at each other in,
in essence,
the way the women had enormous power.
In fact,
the old women rule,
not the young,
beautiful woman like today,
but the older you were,
the more you had control
over our everyone,
including the mating and marriage.
Um,
there were no doctors.
So the,
the,
so that you had the,
you know,
the,
and the old women were like midwives and
knew all the ins and outs of this and I
inherited knowledge
about pregnancy and all,
all these other things.
All right,
I can remember this.
And they say,
and,
and the joy that women had
with each other all day long.
Okay.
Cooking with each other,
you know what I mean?
I companions to each other.
Talking,
conversing.
My mother remembered as a small trial
in Italy when it was time to do the
laundry,
they would take the laundry up,
the mount,
up the hill to the fountain,
it will soar,
go okay and,
and do it by hand.
They would sing,
they would pick nick and so on.
Right.
And we get a glimpse of that
in the Odyssey when a dcs is,
is,
is thrown up naked on the
shorts and fail you all right.
And,
and he hears the sound of women,
young women laughing and singing and
it's Nausicaa the princess bringing the
women to do the laundry where
he's exactly the same thing.
And I,
so there was a,
each,
each gender had its own hierarchy,
its own values,
his own way of talking.
And the sex is rarely intersected.
Like I can remember in my childhood,
on a holiday,
typical,
it could be Christmas,
it could be a thanksgiving,
whatever,
all the women would be
cooking all day long.
Everyone would sit down to eat.
Okay.
And then after that.
The women who were retired on monster,
the kitchen and the men would go,
I would,
I would look into a window
and see all the men,
the men,
would it be all outside,
usually gather on the car.
Okay.
And then a time when cars didn't work
as well as inner today with the hood up.
Okay.
And the men would be standing with
our hands on their hips like that.
Everyone's staring at the engine.
I can,
I went,
yeah.
That's how I learned.
Okay.
Men where we refreshing themselves
by studying something technical and
mechanical after being with a
women for during the dinner.
Okay.
It's not.
So all of these problems of today
are the direct consequence of women's
emancipation and freedom from housework,
thanks to capitalism.
Okay.
Which made it possible
for women to have jobs.
I said that home for the very
first time in the 19th century,
no longer to be dependent on a
husband or father or brother.
Right.
And so this great,
great thing that's happened to us and
allowing us to be totally as sup and self
supporting independent agents has produced
all this animosity between men and
women because the women women's
feel unhappy women today and the,
wherever I go,
whether it's Italy or Brazil
or England or America,
okay.
Or Toronto.
Okay.
The,
the,
the upper middle class
professional women are unhappy,
miserable.
They want and they don't know what,
why they're unhappy.
They want to blame it.
Amen.
Okay.
The must change men,
it must become more like women
know that is the wrong way to go.
Okay.
It's when men are men,
okay.
And understand themselves
as men are secure as men,
then you are going to be happier
than a weak man.
Absolutely.
Okay.
And especially all these quislings okay.
Spouting feminists.
Right.
I want to hear that.
Okay.
I mean it makes me sick,
but here's the point.
Men,
men and women have never
worked side by side ever.
Maybe under farms.
Okay.
When you were like maybe one
person is in the potato field,
the other ones over here and the
commitment during tomatoes or whatever.
Okay.
You,
you had,
you had families and working,
working side by side,
exhausted with each other.
No time to have it.
Any clash of this.
It was a collaborative
effort on farms and so on.
Never in all of human history have men
and women been working side by side and
women are now the pressure
about silicon valley.
They're also sexist.
Oh there there's,
they don't allow women in and so on.
The men are being men in silicon valley
don't like and the women and the women
are demanding that,
oh this is terrible.
You're being say maybe the sexes.
Okay.
Have their own particular
form of rhetoric.
Their own particular form of identity.
Okay.
Maybe.
We need to re re re re examine.
Okay.
This business about,
you know,
they the Ma maybe we have to perhaps
except some degree of tension and conflict
between the sexes.
Okay.
In a work environment,
I don't mean harassment,
I'm sorry.
I'm talking about women
feeling disrespected to how
somehow that would their
opinions when they express them.
Okay.
Are Not taking seriously or or the the
or even Hillary Clinton is complaining.
Oh,
we knew it was a woman
writes something online.
She's attacked immediately and so,
well,
everyone's attacked online.
What are you talking about?
The world is tough.
The world is competitive.
Okay.
Identity is honed,
okay.
By conflict.
The idea that there should be no conflict,
that we have to be in this bath.
Okay.
At probation.